mira durdaine est avec nous et
d'étudiants commerce rappeur et vous
êtes fan de freeze corleone vous avez 21
noms exacts ray c'est vrai que vous
aussi vous faisiez partie de ceux qui ne
comprenaient pas du tout la sortie de
valérie bègue
bah en fait le truc c'est que par
exemple je sais pas en fait moi je
comprends je comprends pas ce qu on sort
des phrases du contexte parce que la
licra adore faire ça sur des gens issus
des minorités de certaines minorités
moi je trouve ça a été des phrase sortie
de son contexte il suffit juste de
écouter l'artiste d'aller sur un site
qui s'appellera genuis qui explique
toutes les phrases voilà par exemple sur
le ra et flash mois avant il dit et sur
l'esclavagé puis sur la route donc big
up alors sur l'esclavagé dit on les
fouette comme des négriers 2008 en libye
ça bibi des [ __ ] à 150k il parle aussi
des politiques bien entendu nos parents
faisait peur à himmler hittler macron
ocz il bernard kouchner
j'arrive à lui mais comme quatre lampes
faut brûler tous les pédophiles comme
jack lang
voilà donc il tire un peu sur tout le
monde c'est son fond de commerce de
faire de la polémique
en fait c'est pas son fond de commerce
c'est en fait comment expliquer ça en
fait c'est c'est quelque chose dans le
rap qui a toujours été comme ça en fait
l'art en général ça a toujours été
borderline bascule un art qui n'est pas
abordée en langue ça c'est de l'art
tiède là ça a toujours été quelques
chose de provocant à l'époque brel à
l'époque gainsbourg c'est pas les même
époque c'est pas les mêmes choses parce
que vous avez des parce qu'effectivement
j'ai discuté avec énormément de
personnes comme vous qui sont tout à
fait poser parce que je parle pas de
ceux qui vous met les réseaux sociaux
les connais les règles
monsieur voilà mise à part les les
justement racing team avec voilà mais
pour le reste absolument pas grave et au
contraire j'ai pris tout le week end je
pense j'ai dû répondre à 200 personnes
au moins à essayer de dialoguer et
débattre je suis allé voir radier news
ce gène j alors vous allez rixe a
justement sur le cachemire net c'est ce
que vous reprochez à valérie parce que
vous étiez assez virulent et comme tout
ce qu'on a pu voir sur les réseaux
sociaux
deluxe et un déferlement sur valérie ça
a été très violent comme exacts mais en
fait le truc c'est par exemple il ya
peut-être à la régie vont apparaître
l'image sur le black fait ce que vous
avez fait avec jean michel maire ils
sont maintenant ça je tente de me en
2013 tel truc violès protesté le bronze
violées donc
2013 sera aussi bon atout parce que moi
mais pour le 10 juin je peux juste dire
en fait le problème c'est que imaginez
moi je vois cette image sur les réseaux
j ai sorti de son contexte voilà qui est
certes un contexte comme free scolaire
une sortie de son contexte et c'est ça
le truc le plus important c'est que
c'est toujours sortis du contexte mais
si on peut prendre n'importe quoi on
sera donc d'accord sur une chose c'est
que justement le message lorsque
l'émetteur faire message qui est border
du coup on ne peut pas le con ne le
comprend pas en l'occurrence là nous par
exemple vous reprenez cet exemple où on
avait parodié une pochette de la
compagnie créole mois j'ignorais
complètement que ça pouvait s'apparenter
à du blackface depuis j'ai appris je
m'en suis excusé immédiatement non et
donc du coup effectivement nos c'est de
notre faute
le message était border il a été très
mal compris et je le comprends
al'inverse également reconnaissez que
votre message est tellement border que
lui aussi l'émission elle l est pas
clair et donc du coup on peut nous aussi
mal le prendre
non mais bien sûr mais de toute façon on
ira les médias un problème ce qui a été
beaucoup reproché à valérie ça a été le
deux poids deux mesures et on va dire on
va montrer où il faut il casser les
acquis et non mais faut se dire quelque
chose je vous avais dit comme aller et
valérie a défendu sa communauté
voilà comme elle est née voilà va mal et
chez vous pour exactement un gros mois
si vous êtes surtout très bien peignés
là et de l'autre côté sur mila elle n'a
pas défendu et qui a pas de problème en
fait c'est que la ferme il a c'est pas
de la musique la ferme et là c'est pas
de l'art la ferme il a c'est juste une
fille de 16 ans qui était sur les
réseaux et qui a dit du bullshit quoi
comme plein de gens font ça sur les
réseaux 1
c'est toujours comme ça dans les réseaux
il ya toujours des gens qui veulent être
provocant pour être provoquant alors
qu'ils font rien d'intéressant quoi
friess corleone lui c'est un artiste
donc s'il ya bien qu'il travaille c'est
un des rappeurs les plus techniques et
il est applaudi pour sa technicité exact
où le rap français l'a soutenu parce que
la licra la kia 1000 tweets en disant
masquera pain culture je crois s'appelle
l'attendait 10 antisémitisme complotisme
à polo jaune à l'arrière du troisième
reich du terme est ce que vous comprenez
mine de rien que quand il ya des jeunes
et des parents ont aidé les juifs qui
écoute ça dans la voiture il peut être
extrêmement choquée mais bien sûr mais
ces emplois là bas c'est ça le truc je
peux concevoir du principe que quand on
chope une paire
buffard était moi me la joues dit la
vérité pour moi c'est de la merde ce
qu'elle a fait est inadmissible et la
bbc mais bien sûr la jeune fille elle
n'a pas à parler comme moi je suis vous
le savez faso je suis toujours contre
les mines de rien mais là si les
discriminations et les provocations sur
les religions aujourd'hui on sait que
c'est un sujet sensible
aujourd'hui on a eu de gros soucis mine
de rien on a connu une crise comme on en
a jamais connu on croyait tous on va pas
se mentir coup c'était la fin du monde -
un moment j'ai cru que tf1 du monde est
ce qu'on a vraiment besoin aujourd'hui
mira de textes comme ça que 2 de
messages comme celui de millas qui est
insupportable
2 je le dis franchement de dessin comme
ceux de charlie hebdo qui met mine de
rien de l'huile sur le feu de parole
dans des chansons de ce rappeur qui sont
inadmissibles
mine de rien parce que les chants qui
ont connu à la shoah les les vins et les
enfants de ceux qui ont connu à choix
vous rendez compte
quand ils sont dans leur voiture qui met
skyrock d'ailleurs qui à skyrock qui a
arrêté de diffuser ce sera peut vous
rendez compte ce qu'ils peuvent
ressentir juste sur cette péniche line
moi cette prochaine tout pour la famille
pour que mes enfants vivent comme des
rentiers juifs excusez moi je vois pas
la suite s'il aurait dit être sûr que
c'est non non non je suis juste que je
peux juste imaginer dit il l'aurait dit
tout pour ma famille et c'est pour comme
les musulmans pétroliers enfin on aurait
parlé je crois pas mais bien l'herbe a
dit tout les jeux et c'est pas une
obsession session non non non on les
fait comme des négriers c'est quoi ça là
vous avez présent de des négriers
l'un d'eux avait raison non c'est une
autre lecture des noms mais quand ils
diront les fouette comme des négriers
c'est juste une punchline c1 mais ce
qu'il aime bien être dans la danse
border line peut aller je veux justement
je vais voter non mais j'ai su attirer
revenir sur ce que vous dites parce que
je suis là vous avez raison vraiment il
faut le dire j'ai écouté du coup de
nombreux albums depuis 2004 2005
il sera capable de monter beaucoup de
choses huawei il annonce a fait dix ans
qu'il est là pour écouter je vais pas
mentir 1 pas 10 ans mais au moins 84 ans
de travail effectivement vous avez
raison effectivement et pointe du doigt
beaucoup d'autres choses que la
communauté juive ou que la shoah et
c'est effectivement mais je le redis
encore une fois à partir du moment où il
faut j'allais aller comme vous comme
beaucoup me l'ont dit avec je suis allée
du coup aller / ap 10 10 ans pour voir
une location texte d'une chanson
vous imaginez que tout le monde ne va
pas voir l'explication texte y en a qui
vont juste c'est juste que tu disais
mirass exactement l'exemple que tu as
pris sur tpb nous combat de fond s'est
fait taper dessus l'homophobie mais nous
sommes tous à des cellules étaient
sortis que vous avez sur les réseaux
sociaux et les zombies ils n'ont rien vu
de l'émission ils connaissent pas ce qui
se passe et il arrive des trucs dans le
slip mais cette fois ci et à chaque fois
on s'est fait taper dessus parce que les
gens ils ont pris ils ont sorti le truc
du contexte mais je suis d'alarmé c'est
un rappeur qui tape sur tout le monde
moi le seul truc que j'ai à dire mira en
ce moment parce qu'il nous reste très
peu de temps et je vais te laisser
conclure moi je pense qu'on n'a pas
besoin de ça en ce moment
non surement tête moi je peux comprendre
qu'on n'a pas besoin de ça en ce moment
mais le son bâton rouge
il est sorti à deux ans le son ou je
sais plus c'était quelqu'un qui est
exactement mais bâton rouge ses sorties
ya deux ans en fait la plupart des trucs
sont sortis ça date de soi il ya deux
ans trois ans après il y en a eu un
autre d un peu plus récents mais il faut
juste se dire que le rap ça toujours été
borderline je suis désolé le rap c'est
pas du big show lien c'est vrai que ce
sont les amis car ici toujours juste et
ne rendent pas les réductions jusqu à
risque par exemple car ici il est bien
provoquant enfin tout le rap et
provoquant de booba il a déjà cité le
jeune mollah omar
il ya plein il ya plein il ya plein de
rappeurs qui ont cité des trucs et fois
en fait faut arrêter de toujours vouloir
tout sortir de son contexte
ayez le contexte les gens allaient sur
un genius lisez